[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler vincent
chauvet maire modem d'hôtes un bon soir
vincent chauvet merci d'être avec nous
en direct parce qu'à être sur ce plateau
philippe bourrier achi conseiller
régional écologiste merci aussi à vous
d'être là une réaction tout d'abord à ce
témoignage à ses missions qu'on vient
d'entendre une phrase importante à la
fin de ce reportage prononcé par olivier
ça ne m'étonne pas qu'il y ait autant de
gens qui ne vont plus voter ils ne
s'occupent pas des gens vous comprenez
cette colère vincent chauvet
oui après ils s'adressent peut-être à la
mauvaise personne c'est clairement de la
responsabilité de son maire le logement
insalubre d'ailleurs cette majorité a
voté une réforme de la police du
logement parce qu'il y en avait
plusieurs contradictoires c'était assez
compliqué moi dans ma commune j'ai mené
une petite très volontariste de lutte
contre le logement insalubre avec la
police municipale c'est un délit pénal
pour son propriétaire si c'est un office
hlm c'est encore pire et donc c'est au
maire de faire respecter la décence et
l'insalubrité il peut aussi écrire au
préfet qui se substitue au maire en cas
d'inaction mais clairement je connais
pas bien le dossier je découvre avec
vous ce soir mais ce type de situation
ne peut pas exister il y à une
réglementation qui est très claire et
des délits qui sont prévues les
tribunaux poursuivre extrêmement
lourdement les personnes qui laissent
des locataires dans cet état-là ensuite
s'il est lui-même propriétaire on a une
question la tasse hennissements
visiblement qui dysfonctionne et de la
même manière l'assainissement est une
compétence municipales ou
intercommunales
il y a des élus pas au niveau du
président de la république mais des élus
locaux qui doivent être là pour
l'accompagner et le faire sortir de
cette situation qui est parfaitement
intolérable sauf qu'il y à plus de 4
millions de mal logés dans ce pays donc
ça va peut-être au delà d'une question
de relation avec un bailleur certes
peut-être pas correct mais on va éviter
de en faire la cible ce soir puisque on
ne lui a pas donné la parole ce soir on
le fera certainement dans les prochains
temps philippe bourge gâchis au delà
voilà de ce cas particulier qu'a fait lu
pour 100 millions pardon de france est
mal logés ça vous évoque quoi l'inaction
des autorités vous l'avez dit le rapport
de la fondation de l'abbé pierre est
édifiant 4 millions de personnes mal
logées ou sans logement on se retrouve
dans une situation un goulot
d'étranglement d'une politique de
l'habitat qui a été abandonnée alors
j'entends bien effectivement sur
certains points il y va de la
responsabilité des collectivités locales
des municipalités d'intervenir sur le
logement insalubre mais faut-il encore
qu'il puisse y avoir des des solutions
de b parce que c'est le cas par exemple
dans votre commune vous est confiée à
sophie lillie à des logements
vraiment inadmissible inhumaines des
marchands de sommeil mais vous savez
cette situation est dramatique et il a
dit quelque chose de très fort tout à
l'heure avec le peu de revenus qu'il a
il ne peut aller nulle part tout le
monde le refusera y compris dans des
offices hlm qui sont saturés et est dans
une situation catastrophique au niveau
du logement mais on pourra reparler des
solutions mais ce qui se passe aussi ce
qu'on oublie souvent dans la politique
du logement c'est qu'aujourd'hui 35 %
des foyers seront occupés par des
personnes isolées ce qui crée aussi la
pénurie de logements mais les solutions
alternatives
elles existent elles existent dans le
sens où il faut bien évidemment
réquisitionné ces fameux million de
mètres carrés de bureaux vides qu'on
peut aménager et tout de suite
rapidement en logement digne décent il
faut que les mairies que les
municipalités soient impliqués et
applique la loi sru qui prévoit entre 20
et 25% selon la densité où vous vous
trouvez et aujourd'hui vous avez des
mairies qui préfèrent payer une amende
plutôt que d'avoir du logement social et
lorsqu'on fait du logement social c'est
plutôt pour des grandes familles et on
oublie souvent les personnes qui sont
seules et isolées
vincent chevet qu'est ce que vous
répondez
aux arguments que viennent de nous dire
philippe borgat chine notamment les
solutions cette critique de cette fois
effectivement qui date de 2000 ou qui va
d'ailleurs s'accentuer puisque en 2025
ça va aller jusqu'à 25 % de logements
sociaux et qu'on n'arrive pas toujours
finalement à faire respecter dans les
communes
et bien votre interlocuteur parle d'une
réalité qui existe certes qui est la
sienne et qui est assez spécifique
finalement à certaines régions qu on dit
tendu en termes de logements comme l'île
de france certaines grandes métropoles
votre sujet se passait à la chapelle de
là en plein milieu de la loire
atlantique et la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un département sur deux
perd des habitants et que dans beaucoup
de petites villes je peux vous citer la
mienne on a 30 % de logements sociaux
vides vides et aujourd'hui d'un
politique du logement dans des villes
comme autant c'est de détruire des
logements vides pour justement recréer
des quartiers plus agréable et aussi
parce que ils sont vite depuis plusieurs
années qu'ils se dégradent à ne pas être
habité alors avant de réquisitionner et
d'utiliser des moyens de coercition
vis-à-vis de 2,2 d'ailleurs de logements
qui n'en sont pas il est possible
d'avoir une autre politique
d'aménagement du territoire et faire en
sorte que et bien dans les endroits où
on a des concentrations très forte par
exemple d'administration ou au très bien
2d metropolis et c'est ce que d'ailleurs
ce gouvernement fait aussi autant va
accueillir par exemple à services
entiers des finances publiques de bercy
qui va qui va du coup être être
localisés dans notre ville mais
clairement c'est pas la même réalité
partout il ya 4 millions de mal logés
mais mal logés ça veut dire aussi en
surpopulation ça veut dire aussi logés
dans des passoires thermiques et là on
est clairement dans un cac ait pas de
mal logement qui est dans un cas
d'illégalité manifeste ou une situation
comme ça ne peut pas perdurer après il
pourra travailler effectivement sur ces
quatre millions de personnes qui
habitent et bien à beaucoup dans peu
mètres carrés ou qui ont des factures et
qui augmente encore parce que les
logements ne sont pas ou mal isolés
c'est là la vraie problématique mais il
faut pas prendre le prisme du logement
sûr
paris ou la région parisienne où il est
impossible de se loger et aussi d'autres
réalités et il est urgent de revoir
justement au profit de ces petites
villes et d'arrêter de concentrer dans
les métropoles et d'entasser finalement
des gens dans des quartiers dans des
grandes villes alors c'est vrai que ce
sujet du logement pour l'instant il n'a
pas vraiment émerger un dents dans cette
campagne présidentielle qui a malgré
tout commencé avant de faire réagir on a
posé cette question alors pourquoi le
logement n'intéresse pas forcément les
candidats sur le conte télégramme
berthier france on a eu cette réaction
elles sont tout simplement complètement
déconnecté de la réalité de la vie des
français beaucoup de politiques ont des
logements de fonction tout frais payés
par les contribuables
philippe bories achi d'accord avec cette
téléspectatrice qui nous dit voilà ils
sont un petit peu hors sol est
déconnecté de la réalité c'est poli par
en réalité très peu de politiques ont
des logements de fonction il faut que
vous ayez une fonction qui va avec donc
il vraiment hormis les ministres qui
sont d'astreinte c'est arrivé
non mais un logement de fonction c'est
qu'il ya une fonction qui va qui va avec
mais vous avez raison sur le fait que
c'est une situation explosive il l'a dit
les français sont énormément déçu
d'ailleurs tellement ça qu'il ya un taux
d'abstention record et de promesses en
promesses c'est un sujet vraiment
explosif et un terrain glissant je
voudrais dire à monsieur le maire qui a
raison sur le fond sur la fameuse
décentralisation qu'on ne voit toujours
pas arrivés au moins vous m'avez dit que
ce gouvernement
va mettre vers chez vous un inspecteur
du ministère des finances mais c'est pas
un secteur qu'il en faudrait je crois
que c'est toute la france qu'il faudrait
décentralisée et qu'elle soit dotée à
parts égales de service public de
transport en commun et je crois que ce
gouvernement a été réellement défaillant
là dessus et surtout là où ce
gouvernement était défaillant ou là où
j'en suis sûr que l'hymne jadot aura une
compétence réelle c'est celle vous ne
pouvez pas régler ce problème juste sous
le prisme une de l'état vous êtes obligé
que vous vouliez ou non de faire une
table ronde avec la région le
département l'inter communauté de
communes le territoire de tout ce fameux
millefeuille qui vient s'entasser si
vous mettez pas tous ces acteurs autour
de la table y compris les associations
et y compris
les bailleurs sociaux eh ben ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que chacun va tirer
la couverture vers soi sur son
territoire a bu ou pas m fera liste mais
si vous mettez pas tous ses acteurs y
compris les associations qui s'occupent
vers les gens qui sont en plus en
difficulté les amicales de locataires
les citoyens et ben ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et donc au lieu de fermer la
porte et de dire que jupiter et le tout
puissant il faut qu'ils apprennent à
composer avec les corps intermédiaires
ce qui lui a fait défaut jusqu'à présent
vincent jamais votre réponse à lui a
fait défaut emmanuel macron oh quel est
son bilan en matière justement de
logements alors il ya eu des avancées il
ya eu aussi des loupés on se souvient
notamment de la réforme des apl où on
avait retiré 5 euros personne n'avait
rien compris et finalement on était
revenu dessus bon la réalité c'est quand
même que ce système des appels
dysfonctionne ça coûte des milliards
d'euros et si ça marchait on n'aurait
pas effectivement c'est 4 millions de
mal-logés donc je pense qu'il faudra une
réforme d'ensemble où les apn dont
certains dans certains départements dans
certaines régions ont fait que tirer les
loyers vers le haut en solvabilise ans
des personnes est en fait en engraissant
finalement des propriétaires dont on
sait d'ailleurs que ce sont souvent des
gens qui concentre déjà beaucoup de
patrimoine donc là c'est très clair en
revanche je donnerai par exemple à mon
interlocuteur la loi qui vient d'être
votée de décentralisation la loi 3d 3ds
où on fait des intercommunalités les
autorités organisatrices du logement qui
vont pouvoir gérer certaines aides qui
vont pouvoir avec la mise en place de
plans locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux
gérer ce qu'on appelle la politique de
peuplement c'est à dire simplement
d'arrêter d'entasser toutes les
personnes dans les mêmes quartiers de
faire en sorte qu'on construise dans les
dents creuses et qu'on fasse pas
d'étalement urbain est aussi une grosse
polémique quand la ministre du logement
emmanuelle wargon a dit et il faut
arrêter la maison individuelle en
lotissement qui est un peu le rêve des
français mais aujourd'hui d'un point de
vue écologique d'un point de vue social
il faut reconstruire la ville sur la
ville et à ce titre le plan action coeur
de ville la densification des
centre-villes retrouver des habitants
centre-ville vous savez par exemple dans
nos petites villes il ya beaucoup de
boutiques lead souvent aussi avec des
logements vides au dessus qui était
anciennement les logements des artisans
et bien la politique est très compliqué
effectivement il faut travailler en
partenariat et ça c'est une vraie
réussite du gouvernement et bien a
permis de remettre sur le logement des
délits d sur le marché des logements
enfin j'en profite pour dire à votre
interlocutrice qui effectivement
quasiment aucun est l'une de logements
de fonction peut-être certains ministres
à paris qui n'habitent pas à paris en
ont et d'ailleurs si on avait des
logements de fonction j'aurais pas
mouche a qui essaye de perturber ce
skype depuis tout à l'heure
c'était plus simple pour vous répondre
bienvenue au au chat film bouriat fille
c'est vrai qu'il me lève un bon c'était
un petit peu distingué dans le
gouvernement d emmanuel macron en disant
voilà il faut oublier cette aberration
de la maison individuelle alors c'est
vrai qu'on dépasse un petit peu de
l'aspect du mal logement qui est l'objet
de ce débat mais ça vous avez inspiré
quoi vous en tant qu'écologiste écouter
lorsqu'on refuse l'artificialisation des
sols nous on peut que se réjouir de
cette situation mais il faut juste
expliquer pourquoi les gens choisissent
la maison individuelle ils veulent aussi
et on l'a vu pendant cette période de
pandémie les parisiens sont devenus fous
il n'avait pas d'espacé il ne voulait ou
ne pouvait pas respirer ne pouvait pas
sortir je parle du premier confinement
qui a rendu à mais complètement
hystériques les gens et puis vous avez
malheureusement des fois pas d'autre
alternative que de vous reculez
ddd points centraux des centres villes
pour pouvoir vous logez parce que c'est
inabordable et la vraie situation là
dessus moi je me rappelle que ce
gouvernement avait promis enfin ce
présent la république avait promis qu'il
y aurait zéro sdf qu'il en ferait une
priorité il a été défaillant de boutons
ou et effectivement cette voie de 3d on
pourrait se dire qu'elle va dans le bon
sens je vais je ne jette pas toujours le
bébé avec l'eau du bain mais c'est quand
même étrange qu'elle arrive aussi
tardivement pour pour un grand
réformateur que notre président la
république ce jeune quadra qui
carrément avait des relents de de
giscard mais pas que dans l'apparence
mais aussi dans les actes le truc il est
bien clair si si vous ne permettez pas
aux gens de pouvoir se loger dignement
si vous ne pouvez pas maîtriser les prix
des loyers il faut juste se rendre
compte une chose très simple c'est que
le tour 9 heures sur le logement social
ces cinq cent mille par an dans le
logement privé ca millions 5 si vous ne
permettez pas aux propriétaires de ces
logements privés d'avoir un fonds de
garantie contre les loyers impayés et
ben vous aller vous allez faire en sorte
de faire la réunification du bien et du
produit et quand tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu que c'était pas des logements
les bureaux qu'on pourrait transformer
en fin de compte vous garder que les
murs externes les plateaux et puis à
l'intérieur c'est du volume que vous
pouvez aménager comme vous voulez on
voit bien qu'avec le télétravail
d'ailleurs groupama avait dit il ya un
an que plus de 30 à 40% de ses locaux
vont rester vacants et c'est là où on
peut essayer de transformer pour éviter
l'artificier sont des sales et tout en
faisant permettant l'encadrement des
loyers et des prix à la fin du débat
faudrait vous faire réagir rapidement
messieurs sur ce chiffre on l'a dit ça
représente une dépense principale
des foyers français en ces temps le
pouvoir d'achat justement est la
préoccupation principale part du revenu
consacré donc par les ménages en
logement 20% 2021 contre 16 % en 2020
sauver café emmanuel macron pour
remédier à cette situation sachant
justement que les choses empirent comme
on le voit sur ce chiffre
effectivement le moi je pense pas que
l'encadrement des loyers soit la bonne
solution encore une fois il faut pas
voir avec le prisme parisien votre
reportage tout à l'heure si tu es un
loyer de 500 euros pour une maison
individuelle
à paris ça paraît délirant mais c'est la
réalité et 500 euros même si on vit
finalement avec avec un smic alors si on
vit on verra ça c'est très compliqué
mais là il ya du logement social mais
cinq cents 500 euros pour une famille ça
peut être ça peut être un loyer qui est
tout à fait abordable et aujourd'hui
beaucoup de centre-ville je leur dise
beaucoup de centre-ville sont tout à
fait abordable il faut pas généraliser
la situation parisienne ensuite il reste
évidemment beaucoup de choses à faire
sur sur le logement la principale action
ça a été et c'est important et
probablement d'envoi de chiffre de 20%
il ya une part d'énergie c'est là ma
prime rénove en france rennes-om un
grand plan financier d'ailleurs avec le
plan de relance européen en partie un
grand plan écologique d'isolation et des
deux subventions directes aux français
pour que leur logement leur coûte
finalement pas plus cher en gaz et en
électricité quant aux loyers ça il
faudra le poursuivre parce qu'on va pas
assez vite et c'est clairement un gain
de pouvoir d'achat pour les français qui
ont pu en bénéficier qui pourront
continuer en bénéficier le mot de la fin
pour vous je suis satisfait que la bac
ronnie prennent les idées des
écologistes et les propositions gaver
faire yannick jadot depuis les
européennes de 2019 mais vous allez on
nous on est pour les bus est libre il
n'y a pas de copyright mais s'ils ne
savaient pas faire voter yannick jadot
nous on sera très bien le faire je
voudrais juste rajouter une chose vous
êtes raison lorsqu'on excentré ben ça
coûte un peu moins cher sauf que vous
avez obligatoirement pratiquement
obligatoirement besoin de votre véhicule
parce que la désertification des
transports publics que vous avez
accentuée pour privilégier les grandes
lignes enfin les lignes à grande vitesse
sont que les français lorsqu'ils se loge
- sont obligés de dépenser plus pour
leur transport donc on saura y remédier
et faites nous confiance encore beaucoup
de pain sur la planche merci à tous les
deux fini borias fille sur ce plateau
vincent chauvet et c'est là